我现在谈了一个男朋友，
这个男孩子他不管从家庭条件各方面他都挺好的，
然后我是已经从物质方面，
从精神方面都已经考虑清楚，
就是我想要去结婚，
我父母这边呢，
他们就不是特别同意，
当时骂我们也骂的特别难听嘛，
就是我妈妈说，
呃，
我不自尊，
不自爱，
我就大概和这些男孩子在外面过，
当时很生气，
我们家就是有那种贷款15万没有还完，
我哥哥也没有去说结婚，
他们就是自己做生意嘛，
我说实话日子真的过得不好，
现在他们都不同意，
不同意的原因就是他们对这个男孩子没有意见，
就是但是呢，
我们就合我八字，
你们有八字不合，
这个男孩子他会克死你，
我就因为这个跟你在一起，
就是反正你不可以在一起，
说他们其实都打算让我读高中的，
说我去读了职校，
我10多岁就送我出来上班了，
是我上班的时候遇到人我一定要去读书，
我又重新去考了，
然后呢，
我才去上的大，
这个大学是我求他们让我去的，
然后我和他们谈好了的，
我说这个学费我交一半，
你们交一半，
大学第一年是他们给我交的，
后来就是我自己去进场打工，
寒暑假我都不回家，
我都在外面上班，
然后周六周天我都在兼职，
我就在超市里给人家那种做兼职，
这些钱就是他们说是他们给我的这个学。
哎，
就是这十多万的贷款是给我的，
就是花在我身上的，
所以我不知道他们现在我爸爸他现在的想法是什么，
就是他是想要我去还这个钱吗？
他说爱我，
让他做的，
这个做法让我没有没有觉得是爱我，
他问我要50万，
你知道吗？
就是这个我是拿不出来的，
你爸爸妈妈问你要50万是吧？
对他们就是说我想要跟这个人在一起，
我给50万就和我断绝一切任何关系，
如果他们能说出这样的话的话，
姑娘我觉得对你来说反而是好事，
如果父母能说出你给我50万，
然后我就允许你跟他在一起，
然后我就断绝关系的话，
这一瞬间他们给了你一个可以跟他们断绝关系的契机，
如果我是你的话，
我凭什么给你50万，
我现在我拿着身份证，
我就可以跟他去领证，
我拿着身份证，
我全国各地，
我哪里都能坐火车，
哪里都能坐动车，
都能坐飞机，
我都能离开，
我又不用受你们的牵制，
我连户口本都不用管，
我凭什么要给你们50万来赎生，
如果是我的话，
我就会，
哎，
我觉得他们问我要这50万，
反而让我自己的道德上、
心理上松绑了，
我心里就不会觉得亏欠了，
反而对于我来说的话，
就相当于他们这个要求一下子把我解绑了，
一下子把我放开了，
那接下来的问题是，
你需要告诉我，
你现在。
谈恋爱的这个男朋友他的情况，
然后龙飞姐姐帮你看一下，
是否值得你跟家里面去断绝关系，
跟这个男生去共同生活，
就是这个男生是这样子，
认识我的时候呢，
比较落魄，
嗯，
他是独立的，
和他家里撇开来，
因为他创业失败嘛，
欠了10多个，
然后他家里比较有实力给他还了，
然后认识了这个男孩子，
他就追我，
这是他得到的钱是全部给我花的，
他现在有十多个存在我这里一个电话赚到的每一分钱都是给我的，
来那我来问你啊，
我V9可能会比较现实，
我问的都是将来有可能影响你婚姻生活是否幸福的，
最核心的一些要素，
就是按照我的思路去思考就行了。
呃，
第一个就是这个男生他年龄啊，
跟你相当吗？
都差不多的，
第二个他是，
呃，
读到什么学历毕业的呢？
他也是跟我学历差不多的，
然后他是大专，
他的爸爸妈妈干什么工作的呢？
呃，
他的爸爸妈妈是做生意的，
然后家里也比较有实力，
就是全款给他买的房子的，
北京全款给他买的房了，
大概多少钱买的呀？
据以说是30多万还是40多万全款买的，
你们家是总共四个兄弟姊妹一个。
哥哥两个妹妹是这样吗？
是的，
那他那头是独子吗？
还是他也有兄弟姊妹呢？
他有一个姐姐一个妹妹，
她姐姐在政府上班，
然后他妹妹现在是医生，
那姐姐妹妹都还是不错的啊，
然后你去见过他的爸爸妈妈，
他的爸爸妈妈对你满意吗？
到了之后呢，
就是他们就觉得我挺乖的，
也挺满意的，
你跟他从认识到现在总共是多长时间呀？
我们认识他在一起的话3年多了啊，
3年多有共同在一起居住生活吗？
呃，
有一起居住生活的话，
他是属于什么风格呢？
就是你俩在家里面家务谁做的多一点啊，
家里面的开销谁承担的多一点啊，
以前呢，
是我承担的多，
但是现在都是他承担，
然后呢？
呃，
他每个月还会固定的给我零花钱，
那你自己是做什么工作的呢？
你应该是从大学毕业了之后就走入社会了，
自己也工作了几年是不是？
是的，
那你大概攒了多少钱呢？
这10个就是你自己攒了小10个是你自己的收入，
然后你男朋友又挣了小10个给你，
所以你是是这么理解吗？
嗯，
是的哦，
那也你们两个人还是挺好的啊，
挺会过日子的，
挺能攒钱的，
那他当初说做生意亏本，
他做的是什么生意你知道吗？
他做那个电商，
然后就没有做成，
然后电脑那些都卖掉了，
然后他给我坦诚的，
他就是把家里就是家里给他那些都还了，
那你现在想要问龙飞姐的问题是，
你应该怎么跟你的爸爸妈妈去相处，
就是帮你分析一下你爸爸妈妈的心态，
是这个意思吗？
对，
其实主要是这个对象这边其实他问题不是特别大，
如果说你的男朋友啊，
第一学历跟你差不多，
年龄跟你差不多，
他的原生家庭啊，
一个姐姐一个妹妹，
人家都有正经的工作，
然后爸爸妈妈还是做生意的，
还给他全款买了房子，
然后你男朋友跟你呃在一起，
这几年的话，
挣钱也需要交到你手里，
然后就算吵架的话，
他也会复盘，
也会分析你们为什么会吵架啊，
情绪如果很稳定的话，
那我觉得他作为一个结婚的对象是OK的，
是没问题的，
然后再回到说你怎么来面对你的原生家庭的问题，
哦，
你看你哥哥也没有结婚是吧，
然后你哥哥也欠钱，
然后你还有两个妹妹，
所以你的爸爸妈妈他有很大的经济压力，
这是一个客观的一个存在，
可能在你爸爸妈妈的心理预期里面，
可能希望你找到更好的人，
这个也属于。
于一种正常的现象，
但是他们如果说去羞辱你，
打压你去，
呃，
禁止你，
就是不允许你跟这个人结婚，
然后说要50万跟他们断绝关系，
那这个方法是错误的，
也是很伤人的。
我觉得这个事情还是回到你自己的身上啊，
如果你足够勇敢，
也你已经做好了这样的心理准备，
敢于跟爸爸妈妈去断绝关系的话，
那你就勇敢追求自己的幸福。
但在这条路上啊，
如果有转机，
有转还的话，
咱们还是可以转还的，
就比如说你们都已经领了证了，
看你爸妈的态度，
真的就是把你踢出门吗？
不让你进门吗？
真的就是不允许你们怎么怎么样吗？
啊，
如果说你爸妈真的很过分，
那你就过自己的日子，
而且我不认为你欠你爸妈50万，
我不认为你应该给你爸妈50万，
因为我自己现在也当妈妈了啊，
就是我们生育一个小孩儿，
不是说来投资的，
不是说我养这个小孩花了多少钱，
这个小孩长大了之后就要还我多少钱，
甚至还的更多，
我们生育一个小孩是因为我们自己心里有爱，
我们自己做好了准备，
我们想要去体验一下当爸爸当妈妈的这种感受，
在养育小孩的这个过程当中，
小孩儿每天给我带来的这些欢乐，
给我带来的这些惊喜，
就足以弥补我在物质上，
在经济上为养育这个小孩儿投入的一切。
所以大人养小孩不应该把小。
而当是一个投资品，
不应该讲的，
这个小孩应该还我多少钱，
我俩才算平，
就屏障了啊，
这个观念是不对的，
所以你自己也要去学会用就龙飞姐刚刚讲的这个观念，
去让自己道德上不要背负任何的债务，
当你的道德上不背负任何的债务，
你不觉得自己应该给他们50万的时候，
你生活会轻松一点，
然后他们跟我说的是，
是我嫁给他，
明知是此路一条，
然后我非要去，
他们是为了爱我才这样，
我不认为他们这是爱，
这是控制，
对，
勇敢一点吧，
姑娘啊，
追求自己的幸福，
把自己的日子过好，
不要背负任何道德的枷锁。
好吧，
大家再见啊，
拜拜，
嗯，
谢谢老姐见。
我跟大家讲一下，
就是在我们这一在我们这一块土地上，
像这样的父母，
他不是个案，
他不是特例，
他不是少数，
在我们这个土地上像这样的父母，
他是很寻常很常见的，
但对你就是控制欲特别强，
他们就是寄希望于你能够回馈他们，
能够给他们，
呃，
挣了钱了可能还他们的账，
挣了钱了之后，
恨不得能够让他们有收益，
比如他在养你的过程当中，
他前前后后可能投入了30万，
50万，
他希望你毕业了，
工作了之后，
你把这个50万的账还平了，
甚至还能有点盈余，
我想对这样的朋友说啊，
就是这个事情看你自己的能力，
如果说你能力特别强啊，
你说你还父母的这个债没有任何压力的话，
你想还你就还，
还完了之后你自己心里可能也就踏实了啊，
也就觉得我我不欠你们什么了，
这样的话你可能就很硬气，
你想去哪里就去哪里，
你不用在心里面再老觉得欠他们什么啊，
但如果你本身也没有这样的能力去还这个债的话，
我觉得大家不要抱有这样的思想包袱，
那老觉得我欠父母的，
其实我们不欠他们什么，
我真是那么认为的，
我自己现在也成为了妈妈，
我。
总觉得我的孩子不欠我任何的东西，
可能他能出现在我的生命里，
我就很感恩，
他能够这个赤条条的来到我身边，
我就很感恩了，
他不欠我任何的东西啊，
这个我突然就是说不上来啊，
就那种感觉，
可能需要我们一代一代人，
当我们这些80后，
90后，
000后的人，
我们当了妈妈，
我们当了父母之后，
我们曾经小时候的那些亏欠感，
小时候那些对父母的那种欠债的那种感觉，
不想再复制在我们的孩子身上，
就希望我们的孩子他出生之后，
他不欠任何人的，
他对任何人都没有感情的债，
没有任何的这个心理的这样一个道德的压力，
如果你们遇到的是这样的父母的话，
就是我希望你们自己能给自己道德上松松绑，
他们养育我们这个过程啊，
很辛苦，
我们承认，
我们也感恩，
但如果他们要以一种债权人的姿态出现在我的生命里的话，
那我要清醒的知道，
我自己不是债务人，
我不欠什么。